[Music]
everyone's got this thing maybe it's a
breakup a death an accident
whatever it is you used to be one thing
now you're something else
we all have our own problems
our own issues
demons
we are venom so we finally got the
teaser trailer and I know he's not in
the costume yet but very clearly we're
watching the suit sort of awakened the
symbiote awakened inside of him when
he's inside that MRI machine like you
start shaking around like oh this is
very clearly after he gets the symbiote
but before it's completely activated so
you can kind of tell that they're doing
a little more agent venom than they're
doing the classic Eddie Brock you know
where he gets it from spider-man in the
bell tower so I think the most important
thing here is in how they're explaining
how the symbiote gets to Planet Earth
and it seems like this wreckage when he
talks about accidents as he narrates in
the trailer this might be where they
find the symbiotes this accident looks
like some sort of crash military vessel
maybe it's something from outer space
but planted to the symbiotes is the
story of a bunch of symbiotes crashing
to Planet Earth so I'm just guessing
that's how they get the multiple
different versions of the symbiote
because you see a couple of canisters
here and you can see the symbiote in it
this is Riz Ahmed playing the Carleton
Drake character of the life foundation
they're the organisation that in the
comics created those five different
symbiotes the venom then had to take
down but it sounds like what might end
up happening because you see multiple
canisters in this truck is that we are
obviously looking at the Venom symbiote
right here but these other canisters
might be the other versions of the
symbiotes woody harrelson is in the
movie he typically plays pretty crazy
people he might get a symbiote Riz Ahmed
character might get a symbiote they're
just a number of people that could
potentially become the carnage of the
Marvel Universe
it'll just be interesting to see how
they weave all that together for the
movie like the movies typically change
comic book backstory a little bit even
the Marvel Cinematic Universe has
changed a lot of stuff like the way that
Tony Stark of the MCU created vision and
not Hank Pym the five different versions
in the comic were screamed Fage riot
Lasher in agony like you see you have
female versions of the symbiote so I
wouldn't be surprised that they whittled
that down to maybe one or two different
versions there's only two canisters in
this shot here so they really wanted to
simplify it they could have just done
the Venom symbiote and the carnage
symbiote and it's just those two like
there's only one other version that he
has to go take down but if you're not
familiar with the light foundation or
any of those characters in the comics
they're really just like an evil
organization that wants to weaponize the
Venom symbiote that eventually Spiderman
invent
have to team up to take down spider-man
was a big part of that story there's
been rumors about Tom Holland being
spotted on set not necessarily in the
spider-man costume but Tom Holland on
set so it would make sense that they'd
find a way to include him in some of
that but if you saw that last teaser
that I posted for it they said that
they're doing the movie in San Francisco
that's where lethal protector takes
place in the comics but the
circumstances for how he wound up there
are a little bit different so if the
whole movie does take place in San
Francisco they do have to explain how
Peter Parker has some sort of crossover
they'll have to be some sort of New York
scene because I don't think that he's
traveled anywhere beyond New York City
and Washington DC because of homecoming
in outer space because of the infinity
war trailer but I know everybody's
wondering what does the symbiote gonna
look like in the film they're using
motion capture so like the same way they
do the Robert Downey jr. Ironman
costumes like you see him in the end o
similar during that infinity war trailer
it's gonna be the same deal for the
Venom symbiote CG has gotten good enough
that it's a lot easier for them to do
stuff like that so Tom Hardy can be
crazy intense and they don't have to
worry about him walking around with
giant prosthetics on but for everybody
asking how this is gonna tie in with the
Marvel Cinematic Universe because if
they do have Tom Holland that does mean
that they're somewhat connected actually
oh no I can't say that whoops
like I've said before think of it as
James Bond level continuity where the
films are all connected because it's the
same characters but they don't
necessarily address every single plot
point in some of the later films
contradict some of the things in the
earlier films so very loosely connected
and I think largely depending on the
success of this movie you'll see them
spin out more because there's just like
a whole universe of spider-man
characters that they'll never have time
to get to in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe like even if they do ten
spider-man films with Marvel Studios
they're still almost an x-men level
number of characters which is like a
whole other story because they just
bought box so there's just a thousand
different directions they could go but a
lot of that just depends on how things
go because people didn't know if
Deadpool was gonna be successful but now
there's like a whole Deadpool universe
that's way more popular than the
traditional x-men films so because the
actual Venom symbiote is such a big deal
and so iconic I think that they'll turn
that reveal into a big thing in another
month or two like they'll tie it to some
big event
but here's the big infinity war theory
so like I said you know Tom Holland
rumored for the movie it's the easiest
thing in the world for them to use the
chaos that's created during the next two
Avengers films to explain how a bunch of
symbiotes could crash to Planet Earth so
I'm not expecting like a big five-star
post-credits treatment during infinity
war or anything like that the stuff you
see during the infinity war post-credits
will largely be dedicated to teasing the
future traditional MCU films like
teasing Captain Marvel because that's
gonna be one of the next big movies
before Avengers 4 and of course teasing
Thanos with the Infinity Gauntlet
completed during Avengers 4 but it is
the easiest thing in the world for the
venom movie to have like a couple lines
of dialogue or some sort of character
explanation where do they say that just
[ __ ] went down in a bunch of things
crashed to earth those things wound up
being the symbiotes but for the most
part the trailer is pretty lightweight
you just get a shot of some of the main
characters this is his girlfriend from
the comics they haven't fully explained
his backstory yet so they're giving him
an agent venom spin that I'm guessing
that he's gonna be an Iraq war vet or
Afghanistan vet but it sounds like he
either gets tied up in this accident and
that's how he gets the symbiote or he
volunteers for the life foundation
experiments and that's how he gets the
symbiote like one of those situations
where they have a number of symbiotes
and they want to test them out so a
bunch of people sign up but most of the
people wind up going crazy because the
symbiote should drive them insane but if
you're not really familiar with the
comics the thing about the Venom
symbiote in eddie brock that's different
is that they form more of a singular
consciousness whereas spider-man kind of
had to fight the consciousness of the
symbiote like he was fighting for
dominance in spider-man's mind slowly
taking him over because of his unusual
psyche Eddie Brock had a much more
harmonious marriage with the symbiote so
that's why they say we are venom whereas
if you were to run into Peter Parker
while he was still wearing the symbiote
he would just say that he has a really
badass costume that can turn into
whatever he needs it to be but now that
we have Cherie in the Black Panther
movie you have vibranium that can turn
into anything you want it to be Tony
Stark looks like he has nanobots that
form his endo similar that can become
anything that he needs it to be so you
have a lot of things that simulate the
effects of the Venom symbiote without
the actual consciousness aspect
like that's the other big reveal that
they need to do in the next trailer is
as what will the consciousness of the
Venom symbiote sound like are they gonna
have another actor voice that as if it's
like a voice inside his head like you
would hear Tony Stark's AI just a really
dark version of that where's it gonna be
Tom Hardy sounding like he's talking to
himself just totally going crazy which
would be a pretty badass portrayal if
anybody can pull this off Tom Hardy can
like he's a fantastic actor so
regardless of what the movie does it'll
at least be entertaining because
spider-man is still like where the
big-ticket items are I'm just expecting
this to be a really fun story hopefully
they found a really cool way to
integrate the character into the larger
Marvel Universe in in success they can
do something even bigger later on but I
know everybody just wants to see him in
the symbiote and see what his voice
sounds like like everybody has Bane
flashbacks what is it gonna sound like
when he has the symbiote on believe all
your questions in the comments below
I'll try to get two of them they'll be
more marble step there's a Jessica Jones
trailer that I'll do a video for soon to
in the Game of Thrones creators are
doing a new Star Wars trilogy so I'll do
a video explaining what's going on with
that because it's said during a
different time period than the current
films but just be sure to subscribe to
get everything make sure you click that
Bell to enable alerts so you don't miss
any of the videos there is a new Marvel
giveaway going on I'm gonna do another
Avengers video tomorrow I'll name the
winner when I post that but click here
to rewatch the Deadpool trailer and
click here to rewatch the infinity war
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
you